he's happy program motion to be moved
formally hi victimís thank you the
question is as on the order paper as
many as other agreeance a I of the
country now as we were hearing there
we've just been listening to the result
of vote MPs have just voted on the
second reading of this brexit Deal
legislation and the result which is
hearing from the speaker john burke oh
there that lawmakers have approved the
second reading of that legislation that
was a result that was widely expected
but basically today was the first time
that mps got the opportunity to vote on
whether to back boris johnson's deal in
principle but it's really the really
important part of developments today is
going to be a vote on what is called the
program motion we haven't had a vote on
that yet that is the second vote that's
going to take place today and peas are
just filing out of the chamber right now
but that program motion is very
significant because this is the
timetable in which the government wants
to push brexit through and the
indication is at the moment from the
government that this all this could be
pulled that if MPs do not agree to this
timetable that this legislation will be
pulled so that's what where things stand
at the moment Lawrence Lee is live for
us in Westminster and so Lawrence it
might not be the absolutely crucial bit
of today's proceedings in Parliament but
I suppose it is significant that Boris
Johnson managed to get a deal with
Brussels and he managed to get a
majority in the House of Commons as well
well yeah I mean that the significance
of it is it's actually the first time
that the British Parliament actually
voted for any source of brexit deal even
given that gigantic reservations at 70
MPs have against aramid syriza may lost
a deal in a meaningful vote on three
separate occasions
and our Parliament's has actually voted
for this but we heard Conservative MP
senior conservative he's saying in their
run-up to the vote look we understand
that you don't like this version of
brexit but it's not about you anymore
it's about trying to get some sort of
brexit over the line and so it is
tremendously complicated and what an in
the meantime as you say they've now gone
out to vote on the on the the second
motion the the program motion which we
can explain a bit now it's determined
could complicate you the planet-sized
brain to understand this and Alan wager
fortunately has one I'm just seeing you
up a bit here how significant first of
all that the Parliament has actually
voted in favor of something even if it
doesn't like it very much
right it's the first time the department
has really voted in favor of any sort of
a brexit agreement and we give Boris
Johnson a 30 vote buffer going into
trying to pass the rest of that bill
through committee stage and through
third reading all the way to becoming
law
he'd have 30 a 30 seat majority there he
could lose 15 MPs during the course of
passing that bill and he would still
make it law so he can now say he's got a
mandate for this and trying to run to
prevaricate and get in the way of it is
getting in the way of a binding vote on
one level
yeah the European Union have taken this
on board they'll see this majority this
third at this 30 vote majority it's not
pure and simple a majority for Boris
Johnson still some of these MPs want to
change Boris Johnson's deal but it does
give a strong indication that if he kept
plowing on and trying to pass his deal
then he could get a could get it through
the house Commons whether or he tries to
do that is another matter and the and
these amendments that you mentioned the
the changes that they want to try and
introduce when it comes to voting on
Wednesday tomorrow based on the rubes
results of this vote do you think it's
more likely then that those amendments
will fail I think some of the more
technical amendments are likely to pass
some of the more substantive amendments
trying to force a customs union with the
with the between the UK and the EU and
and trying to force second referendum
are less likely to pass looking at
looking at these numbers looking at
maybe some technical changes can be made
to the bill to give Parliament a better
role a bigger role going into the next
stage of brexit but in terms of
substantive changes to poorest Ronson's
brexit deal is looking less likely on
these numbers meanwhile they've got us
about another thing now which which is
which is the one that
might lose having won this which is
because the government wants to drive
the entire thing through by Thursday
night to get the UK out as close as
possible to the end of October so many
MPs are absolutely livid about this
because they say they're not giving this
answer look at the detail of this aren't
they yeah so this 30 seat majority will
last as long as it doesn't break apart
give the inconsistencies in Boris
Johnson's brexit position right so the
longer the MPs have to look at this bill
and chew it over the logic goes the more
some MPs that voted for it today will
realize that it doesn't do quite what
they wanted to do trying to pull the
wool over their eyes name is that what
they think
yeah the quicker they sort of bounce
into this agreement the more likely it
is that they were going to find the
holes in it that would stop itstop MPs
from voting on it and that's the logic
behind the government's attempt to pass
it to me and so just quickly we find
ourselves is weird situation now where
Johnson has said that if he loses the
program motion vote the next one that
they're voting on now he might pull the
bill even though he's just won a vote on
it
10 minutes previously this is nuts I
guess it goes back to this do-or-die
press it plugs that he made when he was
trying to become leader of the
Conservative Party and lead and become
prime minister he said that he wouldn't
allow the UK to leave after the 31st of
October
if this program motion goes down it
looks less and less likely that MPs
would vote through all the stages of the
bill before the 31st of October and so
it's become essentially this vote has
become potentially a de facto vote on
Boris Johnson's prime ministership and
whether or not we have a general
election in the UK